two days question there's one tool you
should always use and its up its a dot
diagram okay so in that I've given you I
think I've given your space on the right
hand side where you can draw dot diagram
is going to look like this ok so the
dots will come later what we're using is
two axes to represent two dice um add I
can go from one to six so I'm going to
go 1 2 3 and so on like so this is in
the box and now i'm going to do is
depending on what the question says to
me I might i'm just going to put dots
here or if you read the question and say
ah what am i doing with these two diodes
when I role entail and I adding these
numbers and my multiplying than what's
going on when you have a look just to
scan down a through D most of the
questions I just about what are the
individual numbers together d is the
only one where it's like well what's the
Sun but I think that's easy enough for
us to add in your hands so this dot
diagram for the sake of speed I'm just
going to put dots right which is where
the name comes from so this is what I
would it be acceptable ok um the short
answer is no because you're working out
is this ok so this is this is the way
yeah that I would be looking at as a
marcar to see what's going on for how
did they arrive at their eyelids are ok
because if it's if it's for example like
I could I could make any of those
questions a two-month question I could
if I wanted to ok and if you see that
two marks that indicates to you oh I
can't just put down on but they're gonna
do something something like this
yep yeah absolutely which is exactly
what we do i which is why you wouldn't
see both of the b2 marks one of them
would be too much and then it's like
okay well they're clearly assigning yes
the working in one of these particular
questions let's have a look now yeah
question it was party that was both new
marks yeah so I mean I would do it like
this here's question whatever question
one right and then here's my diagram and
then I'm gonna do a and B I'm just if
they're all referring to this they are
all referred you okay now I said before
I've colors will help you here because
we're going to ask answer several
questions on the same diagram and then
get knotted up twice easily so number
one what's the probability that a one or
two will be on an upper face so we don't
worry about whether there's going to be
multiple of them or not so have a look
at your diagram right you can see the
dots give you the sample space all the
different number number of things that
could happen how many different in done
it there are 36 message so that's not so
hot how many of these 36 have a one or a
two one or two right on an upper face
now for example let's just think about
this slowly if this dire oles are one
right have I satisfied the condition
they asked for this is yes I don't care
what the other day is now right so all
of these guys they all have a one right
a one-under something does that make
sense then what did that mean like the
first one doesn't come
if I have a look at this is there a one
or two on n upper face the answer is yes
there is so I said before you know
principles probably the one thing that I
didn't say when your table maybe want to
add it on the bottom is um read the
question for freely carefully a single
word a single word sometimes a really
small word like a conjunction us over
that will change the question they're
asking you is highly okay is there one
or two it didn't say anything about not
having a double up they could say
something like that but in this case
they have not so this guy's find the
business and you can see based on this
crisp well I can keep going right over
this column once I've got a to hear the
other died can be whatever you like
they're all good okay and then not only
can these new ones or twos but these
ones can be one or two as well right so
I'm going to go nuts okay so you can
also see right one of the modeling
things about a diagram is it helps you
not over count things right not over
counted so up here where I just to say
oh well there are 12 ways to get the 10
to 1 and there are 12 ways on the other
but some of those are the same event
right it's where you get doubles or 1 on
1 2 & 2 etc so how many dots have my
cycling I have circle 20 so all i need
to say is if the probability is 21 36
and it's highly advisable to write down
the actual fraction and then if you want
to simplify that's going to be five over
nine because you wouldn't believe the
number of people we simplify in their
heads don't put the work in and then
they write an incorrect tracking down
which they can't ignore subsequent error
because that's the only thing you've got